let's go next - where do we want to go
next why don't we go - lets go to our
caller from the six seven eight area
code who's calling today from six seven
eight oh that's me Moe hey Moe what's
going on these do well so my question is
kind of the same as the guy that called
in before and it's about I feel like a
lot of people who follow alternative
media have this we underestimate the
power of mainstream media and because I
noticed that with my friends and family
a lot of us a lot of them have their
perspective and perception of politics
completely determined by what a
state-owned popular news network so
basically what I was thinking about is
that most people consume news
intelligently and they're just passive
viewers of news so it's just background
ballast my bad background noise so I was
just wondering that because of all this
misinformation that when I talk with my
friends about politics I know that the
discussion is very minimum and they tend
to use a lot of talking points to handle
issues and I feel like they're kind of
useless agents of status quo because the
talking point you hear don't really dig
any deep on two topics there's no nuance
and discussion so I'm just wondering
that do you feel that or like said you
have a a big following that you could
mobilize your base to have people come
out and we go for like a news report
kind of like ant people who are going
out and advocate for electoral reform
yeah I mean listen I'm trying to do this
so like earlier this week when we did a
story about the testimony of the US
envoy to Ukraine and it's just it's an
argument over whether what the guy says
is credible I took two thirds of the
segment and I said you know let's
understand what what different people
mean when they say there's no evidence
of a quid pro quo and trying to explain
that
the Republicans are using the word
evidence in a different way than what it
actually means and unless you understand
this stuff and can figure it out for
yourself you're sort of going to be
reduced to only pick a talking point
that you like which is basically what I
hear you saying so there's a couple
different issues here one is we can't
really expect people to have a more
nuanced and deep understanding of an
issue if all of the inputs they get are
equally shallow corporate media gives
them shallow inputs politicians often
have an equally shallow understanding of
the issues so unless someone understands
how to get a deeper understanding of
issues again by learning critical
thinking and epistemology then by
actually reading in depth about some of
these issues it's unreasonable to expect
the average person to have a deeper
understanding than all of the inputs
that they are being informed by so
that's sort of number one you got to an
interesting point at the beginning
though which I want to address which is
that there are people who are in the
independent online media space who don't
understand the power that corporate
media still has and you see you know
where you see that really clearly mo
when you hear from an Andrew yang
supporter or a Tulsi supporter who say I
don't think any of these polls are right
don't people realize how much support
these people have online they are going
to win the nomination
and it's like no no no no you are in an
enclave where it seems like Tulsi
Gabbard has huge support or Andrew yang
has huge support and yet they keep
polling between zero and three and it's
not an attack on the candidates it's
just that a lot of people seem to be
missing that most Americans are busy
enough with their lives that as you say
they have corporate news on often in the
background they are not even considering
candidates other than the top candidates
I'm not praising that I'm just pointing
it out and I think that there is a
disconnect that is taking place and
people aren't understanding that most
people's views are still primarily
informed by the talking points that you
get on mainstream corporate media and
you and you seem to be identifying that
MO yeah and I know
because when I talk to people I gang and
other politician I mean other candidates
that are running that aren't as
mainstream that really isn't that much
recognition or knowing who these
candidates are and so I feel like a lot
of people especially when they vote they
fall for that narrative of voting for
who is electable and who could be trunk
forces actually looking after the policy
and having a real opinion that they
could support and then one last thing I
want to mention is whenever I talk about
policy with people and I mentioned
hoping that might raise taxes or involve
government intervention as soon as
people hear that they think socialism
and then they tend to react strongly at
negative faith because they don't wait
they're not really think deeper so I
realized that until we can have
conversation and news media can just
present information without a spin
involved most people are just going to
say oh I fertilize negative things about
socialism the media does a good job of
you know creating that negative
associations so when people here to work
they just react strongly without
actually really thinking about it yeah
yeah I mean a lot of people who have an
opinion about socialism don't even know
what it is and you can be against
socialism and be informed or be against
it and be uninformed and obviously I
we're much better off if people are
informed in their opinions mo I
appreciate the phone call thank you so
much points all all well made